Absolutely!
I think anything else would be...
...strange and untrue. Of course it has.
So can you trust people?
There are so many people around you-
-there's a lot of attention and praise,
but can you trust them?
Well, I have...
I find it quite hard to trust people.
But that isn't because people...
It's not because I'm famous.
It was harder when I was younger
and unknown. That's just in me.
So in my life, it's more...
I'm happily and beautifully surprised
when I find that people are loyal-
-when they mean what they say,
stand by things, and show courage.
So you don't always know where you are,
but you have a house in London.
-Is that home for you?
-It has become my home, amazingly.
I live there, and I have family
that lives there with me.
I've actually started to find a team
that travels with me-
-that goes with me to movie sets
and works with me.
-Has your son moved there too?
-Yes.
-So... You've become a Brit?
-I've become a Brit, yes.
-Nice.
-The most unlikely Brit...
When you gained
international recognition-
-from playing Lisbeth Salander,
you were...
It happened very suddenly, and as far
as I know, your English wasn't good.
-Definitely not.
-Today you're on American talk shows...
...sounding like a perfect American.
You speak it much better than I do.
How did you learn so quickly?
Okay, I actually learned how
in Oslo mostly.
Okay...
I did a film called "Babycall"
that was shot in Oslo.
I think I spent three months
living in Grand Hotel Oslo.
I had done press conferences and
interviews for the Millennium Trilogy.
It was horrendous. I panicked over not
being able to communicate or understand.
I just felt so stupid,
unintelligent, and inferior.
It made me just want to be nice
and well-liked. It was so primitive.
I decided I didn't want that,
I had to make the language mine.
I was in Oslo shooting the film,
and my character was complicated-
-so I didn't socialize at all.
I would spend my nights-
-watching BBC, CNN,
and movies without the subtitles.
I would read anything from newspapers,
magazines, scripts.
It took me an entire night
to read a script back then.
Didn't you have a foundation
to stand on, from school?
I hate being bad at things, and I had
to prioritize when I was younger.
So English, languages, books,
reading, grammar, and so on...
I didn't make them a priority,
I learned other things.
And you have...
You speak English, Swedish,
and some Icelandic?
-And you partly grew up there?
-Yes, my stepfather is Icelandic.
-But your father is Spanish.
-Right. That's next on my to-do list.
-Tell me, your father isn't alive?
-No.
-Did you know him?
-We met, but I didn't know him.
-How did you get in touch?
-We met when I was 15.
My mom and he had mutual friends.
I met him once then, again at around 19,
and then at 20.
Then there was a gap,
a period when we didn't meet.
I reached out to him again
after I became a mother.
By then, he was ill from cancer.
We met a few times before he died.
What kind of relationship
did you have with him?
We reached a point when I felt...
...that I wasn't angry anymore.
I understood his version, his struggles.
It used to be very one-dimensional
on my part.
But I ended up being reconciled.
It was funny, I was holding his hand,
and I have pretty manly hands.
I held his hand, and saw that our hands
were identical. It made me feel...
...a sense of calm.
I felt this anger and harshness
just simmer down.
-And it hasn't come back since.
-Are there other similarities?
I look a lot like him,
with the cheekbones and all of this.
-Do you have a clear grasp of it all?
-No.